the 20th anniversary of the september
11th terror attacks a day that forever
changed this nation
2977 people were killed when terrorists
associated with the islamic
fundamentalist group al-qaeda hijacked
four passenger jets the plane slammed
into the world trade center in new york
city and the pentagon while another
crashed into a pennsylvania field it is
the deadliest terror attack in world
history
this morning a remembrance ceremony will
be held at the national september 11
memorial and museum located at ground
zero the site where the twin towers of
the world trade center once stood
at sunset the tribute in light will beam
twin shafts of light four miles into the
sky to honor the lives lost in the
attacks president biden will visit
memorials at all three sites today
shanksville pennsylvania the pentagon
and first at ground zero that is where
we begin our coverage with michael
george in lower manhattan michael good
morning
good morning family members and guests
are beginning to arrive here and at 8 46
a.m that'll mark the first of six
moments of silence the first marking the
exact moment the first plane hit the
north tower
a lot has changed in our lives since 9
11 especially when it comes to safety
and that continues today as security
officials are on high alert
you mess with new york
there'll be consequences
new york governor kathy hokel promising
a stepped up and highly visible security
presence around today's ceremony you'll
see more people
you'll see individuals
with long arms you'll see them
looking a little bit militarized
the precautions are in place even though
there's no specific or credible threat
directed toward new york city
crowds visited the memorial site
yesterday iowa firefighter nate smith
brought his children so they could learn
what happened that day just to kind of
pay tribute to fallen brothers and
sisters
it's pretty emotional but it's so hard
whether it's the first year the 20th
in a recorded statement released by the
white house president biden urged
americans to not be afraid
[Music]
20 years later americans are still
remembering the victims and the heroes
of that day many of them still suffering
the mental and physical effects from
responding to the scenes of tragedy
this week the september 11th victim
compensation fund said it believes more
people have died from 9 11 related
illnesses than were killed in the
attacks the opportunity for those folks
to breathe in poisonous materials
was there from the very beginning and
stayed there as long as that pile stayed
on fire and as long as they are moving
large amounts of dust
matt komorowski was one of the new york
city firefighters who answered the call
he and five members of ladder company
six survived the collapse of the south
tower they had stopped to assist
josephine harris who needed help going
down the stairs the entire building
around them was destroyed but stairwell
b the spot where they were assisting
josephine remained standing
where she stopped
turned out to be
the spot we needed to be all six men on
the crew and josephine made it out alive
there were so many other firemen that
day that were doing exactly what we were
doing
why we survived we have no idea
now much has changed since 2001 this
will be the first commemoration held
where the u.s is not at war in
afghanistan also a new skyscraper one
world trade center has been built near
the spot where the twin towers fell and
right there behind me you can see the
saint nicholas greek orthodox church
that was destroyed by falling debris on
911 well last night they held an
inaugural lighting ceremony the church
has been rebuilt and will open next
spring michelle but oh so familiar to us
the sound of those bagpipes michael
george thank you very much